[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي بايجاز هيا بنا
ساعات تفصلنا عن اطلاق سافرت الاحتفال
باهم حدث كروي على مستوى العالم قطر وعدت
بان يكون كاس العالم نسخه مونديال
استثنائيه وغير مسلوقه من حيث الامن
والتنظيم ومستوى الملاعب والفعاليات
المصاحبه والترفيه ايضا تقريبا جميع
المنتخبات وصلت الى الدوحه وزملاؤنا هنا
يتحاضرون
الزميل حمزه الراضي قناه الجزيره الذي
يواكب اذا هذه القضيه ويستعد الان للخروج
لتغطيه واحده من الفعاليات صاحب لكاس
العالم حمزه اهلا بك كيف هي تحضيرات لهذا
الحدث
لتقديم تغطيه استثنائيه تليق بهذا الحدث
الاستثنائي كاس العالم قطر 2022 نحن على
بعد يوم واحد فقط مريم من صافره البدايه
كما ذكرته معظم المنتخبات وصلت الى قطر في
انت الوصول المنتخب المرشح الابرز المنتخب
البرازيلي هذا المساء همم الى الدوحه كما
ذكرت الفعاليات كلها تقريبا انطلقت في
الدوحه الفعاليات المصاحبه لهذه البطوله
ونعد ان شاء الله مشاهدي الجزيره بتغطيه
مميزه واستثنائيه لهذا الحدث الاستثنائيه
السلطات التركيه انه عمل ارهابي خلف سته
قتل وعشرات الجرحى خلال ساعات قليله قبض
الامن على المشتبه بها التي وضعت القنبله
اضافه الى العشرات واحيل الى القضاء كحين
تاهمت السلطات التركيه حزب العمال
الكردستاني وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
بالوقوف بالوراء
لنتصل بالاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي الدكتور
عبد المطلب
دكتور عبد المطلب لماذا هذا التفجير في
هذا التوقيت برايك
[موسيقى]
حدوث الحادثه يوم الاحد وهو عطله في
تركيا
باللقاء بين حزب الحاكم بدون حضر والتنميه
وحل الشعوب الدمار الكرديه الوصول الى في
الحقيقه تفاهم حول التنسيق الاتفاقيه قبل
انتخابات التي سيجر في 2017
والمشي في انتخابات
الاتفاق لكن كان هناك طبعا بعض اتفاق
منزعجه هل كائنات الكرديه المساعده
الارهابيه في شمال سوريا هي انزعجت من هذه
الاتفاق ولذلك هم حاول ان يرسل من خلال
هذا الانفجار الى الحزب الحاكم في تركيا
[موسيقى]
مكتب وتحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكيه اطلق
تحقيقا في اغتيال الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله
اسرائيل ردت برب التحقيق والتعاون فيه او
السماح للافرياي او اي جهه اجنبيه
بالتحقيق مع جنودها ووصفت الامر بالخطا
الفادح حين رحبت عائله زميلتي شيرين بفتح
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه للتحقيق
ووصفته بالتطور المهم في مساري هذه القضيه
لن تتصل بالزميل ناصر الحسيني من واشنطن
ونساله عن هذا الموضوع
ناصر اهلا بكم الخطوات التي سيصلك هذا
التحقيق
حول مقتل الزميله المرحومه شيرين امر هام
يغير كثير من الاشياء ولافت في الوقت نفسه
لكن ماذا سيتمكن من فعل على الارض
مدى الرفض الاسرائيلي وتركه تصريحات
الاسرائيليه التي بدات بالربط وبالتالي
التساؤلات هنا هل سيتمكن
من اقناع الاسرائيليين باعاده فتح ملفات
وطرح الاسئله على المتهمين الرئيسيين هذا
غير معروف حتى الان في واشنط شكرا
لعل من ابرز احداث الاسبوع الماضي الصاروخ
الذي سقط في بولندا واستنفر النيت وكدا اي
يشعل حربا جديدا حيث سرع رئيس الاوكرانيه
الاتهام روسيا بالوقوف وراء استهداف
الاراضي البولنديه ليتبين لاحقا ان
الصاروخ اطلقته القوات الاوكرانيه لصد
صاروخ روسي في منفت موسكو بطبيعه الحال
سهله
الصيد حسب قولها كنا سالناكم ان كانت ما
زالت المخاوف متمدد الحرب في اوكرانيا
لبلاد اخرى موجوده كيف جاءت نتائج التصوير
اربعه ولا 50 بالمئه قال نعم
و46% قال له شكرا جزيلا لك يا علاء
الجمهوريون فازوا بالاغلبيه خلال انتخابات
تجديد النصف والسعاد مجلسا وبالامريكي
بهذا الفوز يضمن الجمهوريون وانغالبيه
ضئيله قاعده تشجيعيه مكانهم معرضه برنامج
عمل الرئيس خلال العامين المقبلين من جهته
هنا الرئيس الجمهوريين واعرض عن استعداده
للتعامل معهم من اجل خدمه الشعب الى غزه
حيث شهد مخيم جباليا شمالي القطاع فاجعه
مؤلمه بعد اندلاع حريق في عماره سكنيه او
دا بحياتي 21 شخصا من عائله ابو ريا بينهم
سبعه اطفال الالاف من اهالي القطاع شيع
جثامين الضحايا والتحقيقات كشفت ان وجود
بنزين مخزن بكميات كبيره داخل البنايه
تسبب في اندلاع الحريق بشكل نهائي وطالبات
لفك صار عن القطاع الذي يعاني نقص
الامكانيات وقطع الكهرباء رواد من الصادق
تفاعلوا مع هذه الفاجعه المؤلمه وعبر عن
حزنهم على الضحايا لنقرا بعض هذه
التعليقات نبدا بهذه التي كتبت لم ينجو
احد هذه الجمله ما زالت تعذبنا تطاردنا
لعنه الحروب وما بعد الحروب لا تنتهي مسحه
العائله كامله ولم يبقى احد ليروي تفاصيله
هذه الماسات نحن الشهود والرواد
والمفجوعون خالد يقول يخزن الناس في غزه
البنزين في بيوتهم لاستخدامه لتشغيل
المولدات الكهربائيه جراء انقطاعيا كهرباء
لساعه طويله بفعل الحصار الاسراء المستمري
منذ اكثر من 15 سنه
بهذه التغريدات نصل الى ختام الايجاز
الاسبوع نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل باذن الله
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]